in daylight our Big Blue Marble is all
land oceans and clouds but the night is
electric seen from space
our planet comes alive with light this
new view of the Earth's night lights is
a composite of data acquired by the
polar orbiting Suomi NPP satellite
aboard the satellite a newly designed
instrument called VIIRS is able to
collect what scientists say is a
remarkably detailed view of the earth at
night in some places city lights
resemble solitary stars in the night sky
in other places dense clusters of
galaxies
the satellite can even distinguish
brightly lit boats that line Egypt's
Nile River and the massive flames from
gas flares produced as a byproduct of
oil and gas exploration in the Middle
East as the satellite passes over the
darkness of the Himalayas it shows how
human settlement is bound by natural
borders even political borders are
starkly visible in this view of North
and South Korea and in a line of fishing
boats that dot the Yellow Sea but not
all light is electric glowing just as
bright flaming wildfires burn across
Australia this new view of the earth at
night offers a unique perspective for
exploring the many places in which we
live and seeing the impact of human
populations around the world no matter
how faint or how bright their lights
shine